neighbors in the lake say two more dogs
have been poisoned the person
responsible at this time has not been
caught this is happening near mariner
cove channel rock drive that's between
fort apache and grand canyon drive kate
houston spoke to a man whose dog died
because of this how he's continuing to
fight for answers now it's a brutal way
to get to die it's not quick
you're constantly seizing until
your brain swells up so much from the
seizures
that you essentially die sean cornwall's
beloved dog leia died three years ago
after a ball of meat much like this one
was thrown over their fence it's sorghum
seeds soaked in strychnine which is a
highly toxic pesticide wrapped in ground
beef all she wanted to do is you know
give affection to people and there's a
person like this out there just trying
to
hurt dogs like her kill him cornwall
says this has been going on for seven
years and he says two of his neighbors
moved away after their dogs ate the
poison now cornwall has installed 30
cameras and floodlights around his
property in october cornwall's neighbors
dogs ingested those poisonous seeds he's
now passing out these flyers offering a
reward for information leading to an
arrest despite more than a dozen dogs
being poisoned and some killed no one
has been caught cornwall now wants the
hoa and police to step up saying
neighborhood security cameras are needed
trees lining the fence need to be
trimmed and street lamps need brighter
led bulbs people want it to be prettier
but when you got this going on
you know you need to
balance safety with
something that looks pretty keat houston
live local now